merakını heyecana çevir meraklısın
galiba galiba meraklıyım ya Yani 11
yaşından beri şu arkadaşla kafayı
bozduğuma göre merak dediğimiz şeyden
var bende az ya da çok Evet ben Berfin
Berko Sence lisesinde 10 sınıf
öğrencisiyim ve Aslında hayalimi merakım
ve heyecanıma çevirdiğim merakım
balkabağı gibi doğal malzemelerden bir
ümit ile yani doğayı taklit ederek
doğadaki sistemleri kopyalayarak
biyomateryaller üretmek
Tamam da nereden başladı Yani şimdi 15
yaşındasın o zaman başladığında 11
yaşındaydım Bence her şey daha bu kadar
küçük bir Bebekken yürümeyi bile
bilmiyorken emekliyorken başlıyor
aman aman düşmesin dikkat et bak
merdivene gidiyor Aa çocuk gibi lafları
hepimiz en az birkaç kere etmiş birçok
kez de duymuşuzdur kendi çocuğumuza
yeğenimize komşumuzun çocuğuna Bizim
evde de iki tane merdiven vardı
Kardeşimle birlikte büyüdüğümüz yerler
full mermerdi Yani bir bebeğin büyümesi
için en tehlikeli ortamlardan biri Belki
de ama şu merdiven korkuluklarından
hiçbir zaman olmadı bizim evde Çünkü biz
oraya ne zaman yaklaşsak annem babam ya
da Yanımızdaki büyüğümüz bize gelip
derdi ki bak Merdiven var gidersen şöyle
şöyle olabilir düşebilirsin böyle
tehlikeler var diye sıkmadan sıkılmadan
bıkmadan günde belki on defa bize
anlattılar Bir de iki çocuk büyütsü var
bu şekilde Evet merak ediyorduk ama
gidip atlamayı değil önce bilgiyi
öğrenip sorgulamayı tercih ettik ister
istemez sonra birazcık bayağı büyüdüm
Ortaokulda 6 sınıftayken bir hocamız
vardı fen dersine giriyordu Canan hoca
hepimizin en az birkaç kere öğrencilik
hayatında genelde dersi kaynatmaya
yönelik sorduğu bir sorudur değil mi bu
hocam Tamam biz bunu öğreniyoruz da ne
işimize yarayacak ki zaten Daha sonra
kaynar gider herkes itiraz eder Hoca da
orada bir çamayla bize anlatmaya çalışır
Bakın bu aslında hayatın içinden bir şey
diye biz de bu fen dersinde Neredeyse
her ders bu soruyu soruyorduk bazen asit
baz istiyorduk Bazen en basit işte
maddenin katı sıvı gaz halini ama Canan
hoca bize her seferinde Belki o gün
içerisinde bile görebileceğimiz çok
basit ama hayatın tam olarak İçinden bir
örnek veriyordu ve Bence bu bizim
etrafımıza sadece hepimiz bakıyoruz ama
ben diyorum ki herkes bakar bazıları
görür Bu tarz işte simetri işte bir
bakıyor tavşan görüyor bir bakıyor ördek
görüyor gibi şeyleri sosyal medyada
hepimiz rastlamışızdır ama bence bu
sadece sosyal medyadaki o Eee simetrik
fotoğraflarda değil Doğada her gün
yaşadığımız çevremizde de böyle şehrin
içinde de olsak böyle bir ormanın içinde
de olsak hepimiz bakıyoruz farklı farklı
şeylere dikkat ediyoruz işte ben
balkabağına baktım dedim ki bundan
biyoplastik olur mu Nasıl başladı 7
sınıftaydım Aslında 6 sınıfta fark
etmeden bilimsel görmeyi öğrendikten
hemen sonra okulumuzda yeni bir kulüp
açılmıştı
oranının ilk iki üyesinden biriydim
kulübünü ilk yılıydı ve kulübün amacı
aslında Google Sence dediğimiz bir
yarışmaya bize hazırlamaktı ama ben
hiçbir zaman bir yarışma odaklı ya da
işte ya bu yarışmaya katılırsam şöyle
bir ödül alırım diye merakımı ayakta
tutmadım Eee merakım heyecanım oldu
dedim Tamam da nasıl yani balkabağına
baktım çok heyecanlandım Hadi plastik
yapalım demedim biyoplastik kavramıyla
sürdürülebilirliğin de bu kadar popüler
olmadığı o yıllarda 2017 yılından
bahsediyorum İlk defa o zaman tanıştım
yarışmanın web sitesinde biyoplastikle
ilgili bir proje gördüm ve dedim ki
neden biyoplastik üretilmiş ham maddesi
Ben neyden üretebilirim sonra birçok
deneme yaptım Ee yani yola çıkarken
aslında balkabağını da bilmiyordum bir
sürü hammadde denedim yanıldım bazıları
oldu bazıları olmadı ama ben valizime
merakımı aldım onu heyecanıma çevirmek
için bir yola çıktım hayatımıza
baktığımızda hepimiz Neredeyse her gün
en azından buraya gelirken bile yola
çıkıyoruz ne yapıyoruz giriyoruz işte
içimi ıslak yazıyoruz bakıyoruz
Navigasyondan trafik nerede var nerede
yol çalışması var Bugün yağmur vardı
Acaba nereden gitsem kestirmeden en
hızlı ulaşırım diye ama bir girişimci
bir araştırmacı ya da bir öğrenci hiçbir
zaman yola çıkarken Bazen yola
çıktığımızı bile bilmiyoruz O bir yana
ama hiçbir zaman önündeki engelleri
Tahmin edemiyor o yüzden de aslında
süreç içerisinde Öğrenmek benim bu yol
boyunca gözlemlediğim ve en sık Eee
Maruz kaldım Eee ve yaptığım şey süreç
içerisinde öğrenirken ne yaptım süreç
içerisinde öğrenirken başta mutfağıyla
geçirdim mutfağın böyle %80-90'ı benimdi
işte annem de bir kenarda yemek yapmaya
çalışıyordu Ben böyle gittim Bir gün
balkabağıyla gittim Bir gün Trabzon'a
uğramasıyla gittim Bir gün
Laboratuvardan malzeme aldım Gittim
Çünkü okulda yapıyorduk laboratuvarda
ama
aklıma bir fikir geliyordu laboratuvar
ayarlayana kadar bekleyemiyordum çok
heyecanlanıyordum evde deniyordum işte
önce balkabağı ile evde başladım birçok
malzemeden Sonra balkabağını denedim
Bu aylardı baktım çok fazla atık çıkıyor
dedim ki kendisinden değil de kabuğundan
ilerleyelim Çünkü Sürdürülebilir bir şey
diyoruz ham maddeyi daha da
Sürdürülebilir yapalım ama niye bu kadar
balkabağına taktın derseniz şu
gördüğünüz arkadaş dünyanın yıllık gıda
hattının %2'sini tek başına oluşturuyor
dünyanın yıllık gıda altının %2'si Evet
biz sadece kabak tatlısı olarak biliyor
olabiliriz Hatta böyle görünce acaba
tatlımı gelecek şöyle tahinli bir güzel
yiyelim diye düşündüm Muhtemelen salonun
tümü ama Eee Hayır ben tatlı değilim ya
plastik yaptım süreç içerisinde öğrendim
evde başladım laboratuvarda devam ettim
Hatta şu anda bunu ürüne dönüştürdüm
profesyonel laboratuvarlarda bazı
firmaların desteğiyle çalıştım
Peki bu yol böyle dümdüz demin
gördüğümüz fotoğraftaki gibi böyle önü
açık müthiş manzaralı bir yol muydu
Hayır en az bu kadar karmaşıktı çok
zorlandığım zamanlar da oldu ama ben en
çok zorlayan şey toplumdan duyduğum
genelde de sonunu dinlemediğim laflardı
Buradakilere geçmeden önce zaten
baktığımızda Bizim kültürümüzde
atasözlerimiz çok önemli Orada bile var
ya başımıza icat çıkarma çıkarmasak Ben
bugün niye burada olayım ki Niye size
kabağı anlatayım niye biyoplastik
üretmek isteyeyim başımıza icat
çıkaralım merak edelim mükemmeliyetçi de
olsak ki ben çok mükemmeliyetçi biriydim
mükemmeliyetçi girişimci olmaz Olur
karşınızda Evet çok mükemmeliyetçiyim
ama süreç içerisinde O engelleri aşarken
tüm riskleri düşünüp ekip kurmak lazım
bir yere ekip ben 5 yıldır bu projenin
üstünde çalışıyorum geçtiğimiz aya kadar
bir ekibim yoktu işte Ben senin yaşında
kendi ya Çok yoruluyorsun ama sen de git
hayatını yaşa bunu yaşıtlarımdan ya da
belki de çok farklı jenerasyondan
tanıdığını tanımadığın herkesten
duyuyorum derslerine od yapman lazım
bunlardan İki tanesine değinmek istedim
Biri ekip kurman lazım dedim ben 11
yaşında başladım 4-5 yıldır Arge
sürecini yönetiyorum şimdiye kadar Tek
Kişilik Dev kadroydum Aslında başta
kulüpte iki kişiydik dedim Sonra
Diğerine ne oldu Biz kulübe başladık
araştırma yaptık dediğim gibi bu
aylardaydı ve biz hala hammadde Fikri
üzerine çalışıyorduk bu aylarda bir
delilik yaptık ve dedik ki acaba bezelye
ya da barbunya'dan olur mu barbunyadan
Bir deneyelim bezelyeden Bir deneyelim
Eylül ayında böyle Yağmurlu Bir Günde
akşam ertesi gün 3 sınavımız olmasına
rağmen birimiz bağırmaya birimiz bezelye
aradı hocamız da balkabağı arıyordu O
zaman tabii bilmiyorduk balkabağı
halinde biyoplasti üretip böyle bir
ürüne dönüşeceğini Ama arkadaşım bir
sürü bahane üretip bulamadığını söyledi
ertesi hafta kendisi kulüpten ayrıldı ve
biz Aslında o hafta onun gelmediği
laboratuvarda Bal kabağında denemiştik
Zaten ondan öğrendiğim bir şey var işte
toplantı var Gündem maddeleri
hazırlanmalı o Akşam toplantıya
katılanlara alınan kararlar atılmalı
uygulanmalı gibi artık güdüsel bir hale
gelmiş hani o dosyaları hazırlamak benim
için ondan göre göre ben de bu şekilde
ilerliyordum aşağıya yukarı Şubat
tatilinden sonra Mart ayına geliyorduk
yine bir toplantıydı Ben bu şekilde
kararları hazırladım İşte arkadaşlarıma
sınıf temsilcilerine müdürümüzü attım
müdürümüzden de uzun bir mail aldım
Yaklaşık yarım saat sonra işte neden ona
meyilli ulaşmamam gerektiği de dahil
attığım belki 10 Eylül'de o ama o
şekilde bir tepki aldım Ertesi gün okula
gittiğimde bizden sorumlu olan
koordinatörümüz dedi ki sen öğrenmişsin
Biz öğretmen lütfen mailleşmeyelim
ertesi haftada kuvetip atladı tüm ders
Linklerini ödevlerimle iletmeye
başladılar
Ben de derslerime odaklanırken bir
yandan Heyecanın peşini bırakmadım tabii
ki de
Heyecanın peşini bırakmadım Tamam da
nasıl yaptın yani bir yandan LGS bir
yandan laboratuvar işte gidiyordum
okulda LGS denemesine giriyorduk sonra
çıkıyordum öğretmenler odasında artık
bir hocamızın masasını ele geçirmiştim
neredeyse orada oturup raporumu
yazıyordum sonra gidiyordum
laboratuvarda Bir şey deniyordum eve
geliyordum Bir yandan pandemi başlıyordu
o sırada fark etmeden bizi içine alan
çok uzun bir süreçte o olacaktı ama ben
bu süreç içerisinde öğrenirken anladım
ki hayallerimle toplumumun en yakınıma
ya da belki de hiç tanımadığım kişilerin
beklentileri hiçbir zaman uyuşmadı ve
hiçbir zaman uyuşmayacak da ve ben
bundan çok mutluyum Evet çok zor oluyor
karşınızdakini anlatıyorsunuz işte böyle
bir fikrim var Böyle hayal ediyorum Bunu
çok merak ettim araştıracağım diyor ki
bal kabağıma araştıracaksın bir kere
özellikle böyle bir ürünle fark etmeden
çıktım ama hani balkabağı lüks tüketimi
en fazla kabak tatlısı yapılır yani
bunun kabuğuyla ne işin var senin gibi
ilk aldığım tepkiler genelde böyle
oluyordu şimdi de şey oluyor ya 15
yaşında neler başarmışsın Ben senin
kendi ya genelde sonunu çok Hatırlamadım
Çünkü herkes ya top oynuyor oluyor ya
işte ben arkadaşlarımla geziyordum
oluyor Onları da yapıyorum ama benim
hayallerim bir anda Dursun beklesin Ben
toplumdan öğrendiğim gibi işte 18'ime
geleyim üniversiteye gideyim mezun
olunca bakarım demiyorum Çünkü ben şu an
merak ediyorum Belki o zaman bambaşka
bir şey merak edeceğim Yani sonuç olarak
engelleri aşıp merakımı alanı açtım
buradaki fotoğraftan da birazcık
bahsetmek istiyorum burada bir beton
görüyoruz saksının içinde gibi duruyor
içinden de çiçek çıkmış Bence hepimiz
merakımızı alan açarsak betonun içinden
çiçek bile çıkarız peki bunun hikayesi
nasıl bir balkabağı yaklaşık 10 ila 30
kilo arasında ve bunun %10'u kabuktan
oluşuyor Bu da işte dünyanın geneline
baktığımızda yıllık gıda hastanın %2'si
demek oluyor ben bundan şu şekilde bir
biyoplastik ürettim Bu arada ilk
ürettiğiniz bir plastiğin resmi ve
sonrasında bunu iki farklı ürüne
dönüştürmek için çalıştım bir ilaç
kapsülü şu an onda son aşamadayız gibi
üretime hazır hale geldi
İkincisi de geçtiğimiz Şubat ayında
Ankara'da bir üniversiteden Ee davet
aldım Gittim ve 2017'den beri Onların da
üstünde çalıştığı bir yeşil beton
projesi vardı burada geçirimli beton
olarak tasarlanmış Mimarlık Fakültesi
tarafından özel tasarımlı olan o betonun
içerisine daha beton dökerken tohumları
yerleştiriyoruz Ama tabii ki de
betonlaşma süreci zarar veren ısı açığa
çıkaran bir süreç olduğu için tohumlar
Bunun içerisinde büyüyemiyor ve bunu
korumak için bir madde katlaması
yapmamız gerekiyordu ve ben de Eee
balkabağının kabuğundan elde ettiğim
biyoplasti farklı bir formasyonuyla bu
tohumları kapladık ve ilk defa burada
gördüğümüz gibi o betonların arasından
kendi yolunu buldu o da Aslında belki
süreç içerisinde öğrendi ve betonun
içinden çiçek çıkarmayı başardık Şimdi
bunu etrafımızda Belki yakın zamanda
uygulamalarını göreceğiz onun için
çalışıyoruz Peki bu süreç içerisinde
neler yaptım belki de 15 yaşında neden
bu kadar çok insanı rahat konuşuyorum
bir sürü konferansa davet edildim Eee
orada konuşmacı oldum bazen hikayemi
anlattığım bazen daha teknik projelerimi
anlattım yarışmalara katıldım
ama benim bu girişimcilik sürecinde En
çok beni etkileyen iki tane yarışma
vardı ilki Google sensöre değil Ne yazık
ki ne yazık ki diyorum ama belki de daha
iyi daha büyük işlere girişmemeye
kalkışma mı O sebep oldu Google
yetişemedik ama TÜBİTAK başvurduk Ve ben
12 yaşındayken balkabağından biyoplastik
projemle Türkiye ikincisi ve İstanbul
birincisi seçildim sonrasında geçtiğimiz
yıl adli İbrahim'in iyileştiren fikirler
O yılda bir sürü yarışmasına başvurdum o
zamana kadar Aslında yine kulüpten
çıkmış ama benim devam ettirmek
istediğim bir projeydi sonrasında bu
yarışmada finalist seçildim yine orada
da genelde katıldığım konferanslardaki
gibi aramızdaki en genç olarak seçildim
Çünkü zaten Genelde bizim
ülkelerimizdeki yarışmalarda şöyle bir
engel var 18 yaşından büyük lisans ya da
yüksek lisans Doktor öğrencilerini açık
yarışmalar oluyor bu yılda Eee 4 ay
boyunca bir kuluçka sürecine tabi tutul
o sırada hala Bu arada ekibim yoktu
Hatta onlar artık şey diyordu hani biz
seninle iş planını yapıyoruz ama bir
ekip mi kurstan Hani Niye dün onların 2
dönemi başladı Orada konuşmacıydım ekip
kurduğumu öğrenince hepsi böyle çok
şaşırdı çok sevindik senin adına ama
başta hiç böyle düşünmüyordun Ne oldu
dediler
bu yıldı future'ın sonunda jüri özel
ödülünü kazandım ama bence en büyük şey
her zaman beni dedim yani ödüller ya da
yarışmalar değil de ayakta tutan merak
ettim ve dedim ki Bu proje olarak
çıkardığım şey acaba bir girişime
ileride bir işe nasıl dönüşür bu süreç
içerisinde de bir sürü mentorluklar
saatler süren zoomlar ve sayısız kahve
bardakları sonucunda bayağı bir girişim
olarak hayatımıza girdi marka tescilini
aldık biyoplastiğin patentini aldım 14
yaşında bir patent sahibi olarak
buradaymış şu an en yakın geçmişte olan
2022 yılının Microsoft tarafından
düzenlenen teknolojinin kadın
liderlerinde 2022 genç teknoloji yıldızı
seçildim ve ayrıca okulda katıl Bir
genetik yarışmasının sonucunda devam
edebildiğimiz bir sürü girişim ve
gruplar vardı onlardan da Human isteme
başvurmuştum geçtiğimiz yıl bunun
istemde Aslında sistem alanındaki genç
kızları ve kadınları destekleyen Bizleri
bu alanda çalışırken hem işte
networküyle Hem çalışmalarımıza bazen
firmalarla işbirliği yapmamıza kadar bir
sürü alanda destek sunan bir oluşum ve
ben de buranın ilk ve tek Türk
üyesi olarak seçildim ve en genciyim
benden büyük en genci 24 yaşında Şu anda
Önümüzdeki haftalarda da orada Grand
canboyu dediğimiz onların
panellerinde iki tanesinde konuşmacı
olarak yer alacağım Ama ben bu yolda
öğrendiklerimi sıralayınca böyle bir
merdivene dönüştürdüm Çünkü başta
görüyoruz bakmıyoruz görüyoruz merak
ediyoruz sonrasında Hayal ediyoruz ya
Ben merak ettim bundan nasıl bir şey
olur ve fark ederek ya da fark etmeden
yola çıkıyoruz
sonra azmedip devam ediyoruz bu arada
arada çok defa dibi gördüğümüz oluyor
ama bence en önemlisi asla ben oldum
demiyoruz ve merakımızı heyecanımıza
çeviriyoruz
[Alkış]
[Müzik]